مساء الخير نشره الرابعه من الرياض اهلا
بكم نبدا بالعناوين
اسلحه الغرب معيار روسيا للدفاع عن حدودها
يتهم النيتو بانه شريك في جرائم
رئيسها ساقفه فيانا يزور الرياض ويؤكد
الصبر والشجاعه هما طريقا الوئام بين
الاديان
الجدول حول مواصفات السيارات في السعوديه
مواصفات اقل واسعار اعلى ودعوات للرقابه
على الوكلاء
في الرابعه ايضا
بتقنيه الواقع المعزز الرابعه تتجول في
مشروع المسار الرياضي بالعاصمه السعوديه
الرياض
وتراقب لنصف نهائي ابطالي اسيا الهلال
يواجه الدحيل القطر امال في الوصول الى
النهائي القاري
نبدا من موسكو وتطورات الحرب التي دخلت
تعامها الثاني قبل ايام حيث شدد الرئيس
روسي فلاديمير بوتين على ضروره ان تاخذ
موسكو في الاعتبار القدرات النوويه
لخلفات لقناه روسيا الاولى الى ان الغرب
يريد تصفيه روسيا وتقسيمها الى دويلات
يسهل السيطره عليها بوتين اتهم في هذا
الاطار الغرب وذراعه حلف النيتو بانه شريك
غير مباشر في جرائم ارتكبتها اوكرانيا من
خلال الارسال او الاصرار على ارسال
الاسلحه
واعرب بوتين عن استعداد روسيا للمشاركه في
حوار حول التكافؤ النووي لخلف الناتو وشدد
على ضروره وضع القدرات النوويه لفرنسا
وبريطانيا تحت الرقابه في اي اتفاق
مستقبلي
وزير الدفاع الروسيه قال ان المدى الذي
ستضطر معه روسيا الى الدفاع عن حدودها
ستحدده شحنات الاسلحه الغربيه التي يتم
توريدها الى اوكرانيا
بان روسيا لن تتراجع عن تنفيذ اهدافها من
العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا لحمايه
حدودها من اي تهديدات
في سياق ذاته اتهم نائب وزير الخارجيه
الرومي في الولايات المتحده بممارسه ضغوط
غير مسبوقه على الدول الافريقيه في محاوله
منها لعرقله القمه الروسيه الافريقيه
المزمع عقدها بعد خمسه اشهر على حد قوله
وكذا بغداد في تصريحات نقلتها وكاله التاس
الروسيه للانباء ان الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها يشنون حمله غير مسبوقه لعزل
روسيا سياسيين واقتصاديا بما في ذلك تعطيل
القمه الروسيه الافريقيه الثانيه في سان
بطرسبورغ مشيرا الى انه منذ بدايه الحرب
في اوكرانيا زاد الغرب من ضغطهم على الدول
الافريقيه من خلال التهديد بفرض عقوبات
ووقف المساعدات
هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه مزاعم مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
بالاستيلاء على قريه
اوكرانيا وقالت ان روسيا تواصل اليوم
تركيزه هجومها على طول خط الجبهه فيباخمه
باكمله
هذا وقال العقيده في الجيش الاوكراني يريد
لشبكه سي ان ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحافظ
على مواقعها حول باخموت على الرغم من
تحشيد كبير القوات الروسيه بالقرب من
البلده الشرقيه اكدما ديار ان القوات
الاوكرانيه احتفظت بمواقعها في جميع
المداخل الثلاثه وان عمليات هجوم العدو
باءت بالفشل ولم تحقق نجاحات اقليميه على
حد وصفه متوقعان ان يشن الروس عده عمليات
هجوميه مركزهم الكبير
[موسيقى]
نشرت الدفاع البريطانيه صوره عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه لمركبات روسيه مدمره تقول انها
تابعه لقوات النخبه بالفوج 155 من مشاه
البحريه الروسيه في منطقه فوليدار في
اقليم دانيت وذكرت الوزاره في بيانها
اليوميه ان هذه القوات كانت في طليعه
المهمات التكتيكيه في منطقه فوليدار على
عكس المعتاد حيث تقوم القوات المحموله جوا
بهذه المهمات ولفتت الى ان مشاه البحريه
الروسيه تكبدت خسائر وصفتها بالثقيله في
بوليتر
وقد اكد نائب رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه فاديم ان الهجوم المضاده
الاوكراني القادم في الربيع يهدف الى دق
اسفين في الجبهه الروسيه في الجنوب بين
شبه جزيره القرم والبر الرئيسيه لروسيا
وقال انه يعتقد انه اوكرانيا ستكون جاهزه
لهجومها المضاده في الربيع لكنه قال ان
اللحظه المحدده لبدء الهجوم ستعتمد على
عدد من العوامل بما في ذلك توريد الاسلحه
الغربيه مؤكدا بان القوات الاوكرانيه
ستتوقف عندما تعيد البلاد الى حدود عام 91
العربيه احمد باكاتو اهلا احمد ضعنا في
اخر التطور
نعم اهلا خالد دعنا نتحدث بدايتنا عن
الامور العسكريه ما زالت محاولات الهجوم
المستمره من قبل القوات الروسيه تحديدا
قوات مستمره محاولات لتطويق القوات
الاوكرانيه المتواجده هناك هناك اعتراف من
قبل
العسكريين الاوكران انهم يتراجعون لكن هذه
التراجعات هي تراجعات ليست بالكبيره
تراجعات تكتيكيه كما يقولون تحت وطاهه
النيران المدفعيه القويه للقوات الروسيه
عمليات التطوير تاتي من الجنوب ومن الشمال
للقوات الروسيه التي تحاول السيطره على
هذه المدينه الاستراتيجيه الهامه لتفتح
بعد ذلك الطرق الى مدن اخرى كاسلوف يانسك
وكذلك ايضا كراماتولوسك التي سقط فيها
صاروخ هذا الصباح واسفر عن اصابه عدد من
افراد ايضا هناك نيران المدفعيه التي بدات
في الوصول الى المنطقه او الجبهه الشماليه
تحديدا منطقه سومي وهذه الجبهات هادئه بعض
الشيء اذا بالجبهه الشرقيه وصل عدد من
الاشخاص بعضه الى المستشفى بعضهم في حاله
خطيره وفقا للقياده المحليه هناك
القوات الاوكرانيه خالد تتبع الطريقه يعني
مستمره خلال فتره الماضيه
لمنع تقدم القوات الروسيه اذا ما اضطرت
للتراجع هي تقوم بتفجير الجسور او السدود
او كذلك الطرق حتى تمنع قوات الروسيه من
التقدم القوات الروسيه في هجومها بصوره
تامه تحاول تطويق القوات الاوكرانيه ومنع
وصول امدادات اليها لكن حتى لان هذا لم
ينجح وفقا لما تقوله القوات الاوكرانيه
التي تستهدف بصوره مستمره عن طريق الطيران
المصير الذي يعني تستفيد منه بصوره كبيره
قوات الاوكرانيه على حد وصفها في استهداف
بعض مواقع المدفعيه الاوكرانيه وكذلك
تمركزات القوات الروسيه في المناطق
المختلفه
سياسيا تم الحديث او اعلن رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني عندما سئل عن مصالحه مع روسيا
الحديث عن المصطلحات المستمره والمبادرات
قال انه لا يتوقع وجود مصالحه خلال مئه
عام المقبله خاصه انه لا يوجد تغيير في
روسيا نحن لا نتصالح مع روسيا الا عندما
يكون هناك ديمقراطيه فيها لذلك ربما هذا
يعكس ان اي حديث عن مصالحه وتسويه ربما
يكون بعيد بعض الشيء هناك مطالبات مستمره
يعني وصول المزيد من الاسلحه من الغرب
بالطبع هذه الاسلحه بعد ان تصل دبابات
وانظمه الدفاع ورادار وغيرها الحديث الان
عن طائرات اف 16 يعني تريد القياده
العسكريه الاوكرانيه يعني تشترك معها في
الحرب وان تصل يعني وتكون من ضمن الدفعات
الجديده من الاسلحه هذا الامر لم يتم
تاكيده حتى الان لكنه طلب من الجانب
الاوكراني حتى يعني يساعد في الهجوم
المضاده الذي يتحدث عنه القياده العسكريه
والسياسيه هنا في اوكرانيا بالنسبه
للمواطنين المواطنون يعني يشعرون انهم
يعني لا يعرفون ماذا سيحدث لكنهم يريدون
هذه الحرب ان تقف باي طريقه البعض يريد ان
تعود كامل اراضي الاوكرانيه الى السياده
الاوكرانيه البعض يريد لهذه الحرب ان تقف
باي طريقه وباي تسويه كانت لان هذا الامر
اثر بصوره كبيره عليهم في معيشتهم وفي
تجارتهم وفي غيرها نحن كنا يعني قبل يومين
ذهبنا الى دينيبرو الان في خار كيف في
طريقنا الى كيف عندما تسير في هذه الطرقات
خالد يعني جميع الطرقات بها نقاط عسكريه
هناك حاله من تشعر ان البلاد في منطقه حرب
ان المواطنون يعني يشعرون ان الامور باتت
سيئه للغايه هم يريدون هذه الحرب ان تنتهي
باي صوره كانت وان كان لكل مبرره ولكل
غاياته في ان تنتهي هذا الحرب سواء بتسويه
او سواء في اعاده كامل اراضي الاوكرانيه
الى الدوله الاوكرانيه الى حد وصفهم شكرا
جزيلا لك احمد بقات العربيه الى خارجه
شكرا
[موسيقى]
في مقابله خاصه للعربيه اكد الحاكم
العسكري والمدني لاقليم لوغانست للعربيه
تحرير اربعه عشره منطقه سكنيه من سيطره
الروس فيما تدور معارك عنيفه على ثلاثه
محاور اخرى وعرب حاكم عن امله بوصول
الاسلحه الغربيه ليشن هجوم مباغت وتحرير
لوغانسك
الوضع في اقليم
حررنا اربع عشره منطقه سكنيه وهناك تصعيد
على جبهات عده لدينا ايضا ثلاثه محاور
مهمه هي بايل جورسكاو وكريمينال وسفات
كوبينز يتصاعد فيها القتال بنسبه لروسيا
انها التجهيز الكثير من المجندين الجدد
ولديها جنود في لوغانسك والكثير من
الاليات موجهه الى خط التماس حيث تدور
معارك وعنيفه فيما تحافظ قواتنا الدفاعيه
علم واقعها ونامل وصول الاليات الثقيله
الهجوميه من حلفائنا في الغرب
نتمكن من شن هجوم مباغت ونحرر لوغاسك
لن نقبل باي صيغه للسلام بينما تبقى اراضي
لوغانسك تحت السيطره روسيا التي تفاق مع
بوتين لا يعني شيء فهو يكذب دائما وكلنا
يتذكر ما قاله عن القرم ان جيشه لا يحتلها
بعدها قال ان الجيش الروسي لم يكن هناك
ابدا ثم عاد يتحدث عن الشعور بالفخر
باحتلال قواته القرن ايضا قبل بضعه ايام
من بدايه غزوه لاوكرانيا سالوه وقادته
العسكريين هل ستندلع الحرب اجاب كلهم لن
تكون هناك حرب اي اتفاق مع بوتين سيكون
حبرا على ورق لانه سيهاجموننا من جديد لن
تاجر باراضينا هذا موقف واضح من الرئيس
زيلينسكي والاوكرانيين
ضعفوا بصره بعد عام من الحرب هدم صرح به
الرئيس اوضعه فبصره هذا ما صرح به الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير فيلم وثائقي وعزل
اسباب الى عمله في الاضاءه الخفيفه طوال
فتره الحمل
[موسيقى]
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل جدل حول
مواصفات السيارات في السعوديه مواصفات اقل
واسعار اعلى ودعوات للرقابه على الوكاله
اهلا بكم من جديد في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض استقبل الامين العام لرابطه العالم
الاسلامي الدكتور محمد العيسى رئيس اساقفه
فيينا الدكتور كريستوف شامبو خلال لقاء
ناقش الجانبان عددا من القضايا ابرزها
اهميه التعاون والتواصل الفاعل بين قاده
الاديان في مواجهه افكار ودعوات اصطدام
الحضري كما اشاد الكاردينال شومبران
باعمال رابطه العالم الاسلامي ومبادرتها
الدوليه وكدا تطلعه للعمل في المستقبل
معها هذا ويعد رئيس اساقفه فينا من ابرز
القيادات الدينيه الفاعله في مجال التعزيز
الصداقه والتعاون بين الحضارات
وقد عبر رئيس اساقفه فيانا الدكتور
كريستوف شامبونان سعادته بوجود تواصل دائم
بين رابطه العالم الاسلامي والفاتيكان
مؤكدا ان الاديان هي الطريق نحو السلام
والتعيش
اشعر ببالغ السعاده لوجود هذا التواصل
الدائم بين رابطه العالم الاسلامي
والفاتيكان وما اراه على قدر كبير من
الاهميه هو نقل هذا الحوار وعلاقه الاخوه
هذه الى اجيال المستقبل وجيل الشباب يشكل
65% من اجمالي سكان هذه الدوله الجميله
والمهمه نحتاج ان نقرب الاديان من بعضها
البعض فهناك كثير في هذا العالم ممن يرون
ان الاديان تشكل خطرا تخلق الكراهيه
والنزاعات على الاقل في اوروبا هناك
كثيرون لا يثقون بالاديان ونحن علينا ان
نثبت لهم ان الاديان هي الطريق نحو السلام
والتعايش
واشار ايضا رئيس ساقفه فيينا الى ان رابطه
العالم الاسلامي تركز على ضروره التعاون
بين الحضارات وليس على اصطدام بينها
معتبرا ان الصبر والشجاعه هما كل ما
تحتاجه الشعوب
رابطه العالم الاسلامي تركز على مساله عدم
حتميه صدام الحضارات بل تؤكد على ضروره
التعاون بين الحضارات بوسع فقط ان اكرر
نصيحه التي قدمها هو بنفسه وهي الصبر
والشجاعه هذا كل ما نحتاج اليه الصبر لان
الاشياء قد لا تتحرك بسرعه التي نريدها
وبالتالي علينا الصبر وعدم الياس ان
واجهتنا اي تداعيات وهنا اكرر ما قاله
الشيخ العيسى اليوم وارى ان هذا امر فيه
حكمه وصدق
جدل يتكرر في السعوديه حول قطاع السيارات
هذه المره عن المواصفات ولماذا تختلف من
دوله الى اخرى زميل العنود العبدلي تاخدنا
لنتعرف على تفاصيل هذا المتابع
مواصفات اقل واسعار اعلى جمله مختصره
للجدل المستمر حول قطاع سيارات في
السعوديه حيث تدور الكثير من التساؤلات
حول السيارات ومقارنه مواصفاتها في الدول
الاخرى بعض المغردين اتهم وكلاء السيارات
بالجشع فيما ذهب البعض الاخر الى وصف ما
يحدث من تغيير في المواصفات سرقه قانونيه
مطالبين باعاده النظر في القطاع على جميع
الاصعده وتفعيل الدوره الرقابيه على شركات
السيارات
وزير التجاره السعوديه الدكتور ماجد
القصبي كشف قبل اسابيع قليله ان استيراد
سيارات غير مقصور على وكالات السيارات وان
تحديات جائحه كورونا تسببت في ارتفاع
اسعارها
الاستيراد استيراد السيارات
غير مقصور على وكلاء السيارات
يعني الافراد يستطيع ان يستوردوا اصحاب
المعارض يستطيع ان يستوردوا كل واحد فينا
يحق له ان يستورد
المشكله بدات من بدايه الجائحه
انه تحديات الجائحه
انتقلت الى المصانع السيارات
فانخفض الانتاج مقابل الطلب مستمر كما هو
بالاضافه الى
التحديات اللي واجهناها في سلاسل
الامدادات من الشحن والانتاج وموضوع
الميكرو تشيبس وكلكم عارفين المشكله
فالتحدي هذا كان كله
عالمي
وحول استيراد سيارات اوضح وزير تجاره
السعوديه ان الاولويه خلال الفتره المقبله
ستكون للافراد مع تقليل حصه الوكلاء لكن
في المقابل هناك الكثير من التحديات التي
تواجه الافراد عند استيراد السيارات من
ابرزها الرسوم الجمركيه والضرائب اضافه
الى تحدي ادخالها في خدمات الضمان على
الصيانه لدى الوكلاء داخل السعوديه ومن
التحديات ايضا مشاهدينا تعطل اجراءات
الاستيراد واخذها وقتا اكثر من اللازم ما
سبق وعدنا الى النقطه الاولى مواصفات
السيارات والتساؤل الابرز هنا هل يحق
للوكلاء التدخل في تغييرها عن مواصفات
الشركه الام ولماذا نجد فارقا كبيرا فيها
من دوله الى اخرى
جدا نتابع مع خبير ومختص السيارات ماجد
الشيخي حياك الله سيد ماجد انت شايف
الواقع عندنا بهذا الشكل يعني المواصفات
عندنا مقارنه بالدول الاخرى المجاوره يعني
اقل والاسعار اعلى بشكل مبالغ فيه
والله شوف طال عمرك اول حاجه كقضيه
مواصفات المواصفات هذه طبعا يختارها
الوكيل المصنع تماما ما له اي علاقه في
المواصفات قبل ما تيجي السياره انتاج جديد
تنزل السوق قبل فتره المصنع يرسل الوكيل
او يرسل ملف كامل يرسل الوكيل تفضل يا
حبيبي اوكي في السعوديه في الامارات في
الكويت في مصر في سوريا في اي مكان يناسبك
في اي مكان هو عفوا
اختر لي المواصفات كامله اللي تبغاها
الفئات اللي تبغاها المحركات اللي انت
تشوف سوقك انه يبيعها ليش لانه لو بكره
الصباح الوكيل والله او المصنع لو حددت
المواصفات اللي هو
يبغاها وبكره الصباح الوكيل ما باع
السيارات اللي عنده في السوق السعودي مثلا
هيقول وكيل والله شفتها مصنع انت اخترت
المواصفات المواصفات هذه ما تناسب سوقي
انا اعرف عملائي اعرف نوعيتهم اعرف ايش
يبغون فهذا اللي انا نوفره لهم نعم حقيقه
في بعض الوكل عندها للاسف في السوق
السعودي
بيلعبوا في المواصفات بشكل جدا جدا كبير
لكن للاسف في ناس بتشتري طالما انه في ناس
بتشتري الناس ما تعرف
اليوم
الاسد خالد اليوم
من الزوم عفوا اليوم الانترنت ما شاء الله
موجود في كل بيت اليوم اي واحد اليوم حتى
الطفل الصغير ممكن يفتح جوال ويطلع
السيرفر يطلع مواصفاته في امريكا في
استراليا في اوروبا في كل دوله في العالم
فما حتفرق معاه بالعكس لكن للاسف في نوعيه
ناس عندنا انا عندي بعض الزملاء يا ماجد
يعني يعني معلش لو اقول لكم والله تضحكون
قول لي بعض الوكاله يعني يسبوا بعض
الوكاله بشكل مخيف يا حبيبي اذا الوكيل ما
وفر لك للسياره تبغى يا اخي في بديل عنه
يعني مو لازم تشتري السياره هذه الفلانيه
والله انا ما ابغى السياره هذه لا يا
حبيبي في سيارات كثيره
بهذا الشكل يعني يطلب مواصفات اقل وفي نفس
الوقت يرفع السعر بشكل مبالغ فيه يعني
اقول لكم على حاجه يمكن كثير انا من زمان
في سوق السيارات واعرف خفايا كثيره الناس
كثير ما تعرفها خلينا نتكلم عن سوق
الخليجي مثلا
بعض الاسواق الخليجيه تجي السيارات مثلا
خلينا نتكلم اقول من اليابان
الوكيل مباشره يجيبها على طول مباشره
يبيعها ما يتحمل لا مستودعات ولا خدمات
لوجستيه ما يتحمل اي تكاليف اضافيه على
السياره جاتوه من اليابان من الميناء على
طول دخلها في سوق في عندنا في الخليج
مشهور طبعا باع السيارات مباشره ما تكلف
عليها اي تكاليف اضافيه حلو فبذلك بتلاقي
الاسعار بعض السيارات في السوق الخليجي
نعم ارخص من السوق السعودي بفارق كبير بعض
المرات بيكون انه في بعض الاكله في الخليج
عنده ستوك عدد كبير من السيارات منبع
فبيروحوا التجار السعوديين هناك بعض
المعارض مثلا خلينا نتكلم اقول والله مثلا
دبي او يعني السوق الخليجيه بصفه عامه حتى
في الكويت مثلا حصل انه والله في تجار
سعوديين راحوا الكويت والله يقول لك
الوكيل في الخليج بدل انا ما اقصف في
سياراتي خليني ابيعها لاي موزع في
السعوديه لان السعوديه ما شاء الله الله
يبارك في بلدنا اكبر سوق سيارات في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط كله فيقول لك خلينا ندخلها
السعودي مثلا بدل ما اخسر فيها خليني ابيع
حتى لو اكسب في كل سياره 200 ريال ولمئه
ريال في الاخير في الاول والاخير انا
كسبان كوكيل في الخليج فعشان كذا الناس
بتشوف انه في فرق كبير بين جدا كبير نعم
زي ما قلت لك انه بدل ما يخسر فيها الوكيل
في الخليج يدخلها السوق السعودي ويبيعها
او انه والله الوكيل اللي جابها من هناك
مباشره من الميناء اخذها ودخلها سوق
البريمي وباعهم مباشره يعتبر دخلوا
السعوديه لا لا
ابدا ابدا بشكل نظامي جدا بالعكس سيارات
انت لو عارف فين مصدر السياره انت كوكيل
عفوا كعميل سعودي ودخلت السياره انت والله
صاحي المعرض انا رحت والله البريمي اشتريت
سيارات لكن اتاكد انا من بلد المنشا اتاكد
من كتيب المالك اتاكد من ختم الوكيل اللي
في الخليج عشان لما ادخل انا السياره
السوق السعودي الوكيل في السوق السعودي
ضمنها ما عنده اي مشكله لكن في بعض
السيارات للاسف يعني اقول لكم قصص لو في
وقت كلكم قصص والله تضحكون سريعا يعني في
واحد من الشباب سمعت عنه اشترى سياره
فاخره من دبي وجاب السعوديه جديده ماشيه
شيء بسيط دخلها السوق السعودي اخذها يمكن
بنص القيمه تخيلوا وجافها عند الوكيل هنا
قال له مشى في السياره 5000 وعشره قالت
اتفضل هذه سيارتي اعمل لها صيانه
من دبي تخيلوا السياره بحثوا بحثوا بحثوا
السياره التاجر في الامارات اللي باع
السياره للعميل السعودي السياره اصلا ما
قبل الانتاج تخيل يعني هذا جابها المصنع
للسوق الخليجي عشان يجربونها يسمونها
نسميها في اي مصطلح في سوق السيارات يسموه
بروتو تايم في سوق السيارات عفوا
فالمصنع عمل تجاربه على السياره في السوق
الخليجي في الصيف في الشتاء جرب المكيف
جرب السياره كيف الحفر والمطبات جرب
السياره في في كل شيء اخذ السياره وباعه
على اساس انها تالف لحد الاشخاص احد
الاشخاص اخذها وباعها لواحد سعودي ودخلها
السعوديه فرحان
ما قبل الانتاج تخيل فترى قصص كثير تعدد
علينا احنا القصص اللي عدت عليها انا
شخصيا وسمعت الشباب جاءت سيارات من فئه
سيارات
دخلت السوق السعودي برضو تقريبا بمبلغ جدا
خرافي اشتراها الشباب فرحان فرحانين فيها
اكتشفوا بعدين انه مواصفاتها ومواصفات
السوق الروسي تخيل غير مطيقه تماما للسوق
الخليجي طيب ايش الفرق بين المواصفات وبين
الاكسسوارات يمكن في ناس يلتبس عليهم
الامر في فرق بينهم
نعم في فرق كبير جدا الاكسسوارات انت تقدر
تستغني عنها عفوا يعني مثلا لو اقول لك
انا والله كوكيل
كوكيل انا اجيب من المصنع والله احط احط
لك شاشه مثلا ثمانيه انشات لكن لا اقدر
ابدلها باكسسوار بشاشه 12 انش حتكون طبعا
اكيد اجمل افخم مواصفاتها افضل لكن حتدفع
عليها مبلغ اكبر عرفت هو هذا الفرق ما
بينها والله انا اجيب سياره شنطه مثلا 17
كستاندر لكن اقدر احط عليها اكسسوارات الى
جنط الى
فهي هذه فرق المواصفات طيب اليوم انت شايف
الواقع اختلف يعني قبل في ايام الماضيه
القليله كانت تنشر بعض الفيديوهات عن
انخفاض اسعار السيارات زي الكامري وزي
غيرها من السيارات هل هذا صحيح ام انه
مازلنا احنا لانه كمان الامر كان مكان
اختلاف البعض او الكثير يقول انه لم يحصل
اي اختلاف ما زالت اسعار السيارات مرتفعه
وترتفع كمان
ما قبل ازمه كورونا وما بعد ازمه اربع
ايام اللي راحت يعني انا شفت في اكثر من
صحيح في في بعض التذبذب في بعض السيارات
الكامري مثلا شوف سوق السيارات الان
الفتره الحاليه للاسف اصبح زي سوق الاسهم
او الذهب ما بين طالع ونازل ليش حسب
التوافر فاذا توفرت والله السياره بكميه
كبيره لدى الوكيل مباشره
حينزل سعرها اذا والله للاسف ايوه قلت عند
الوكيل للاسف بعض اصحاب المعارض للاسف
الشديد حيرفع اسعاره للاسف الشديد هذه
النقطه بوقف عندها وبتطرق لها بشكل كبير
انه حقيقه الارتفاعات الكبيره قاعدين
نشوفها في اسعار سوق السيارات في سوقنا
للاسف السبب فيها بعض اصحاب المعارض حقيقه
للاسف الشديد وزاره تجاره قامت بجولات
ولكن للاسف لا زاد مقصره جدا بشكل كبير
جدا سمعنا قبل يمكن اسبوعين تقريبا في
الحدود هذه قرار جديد انه الان وقف يعني
انت كوكيل لا تعطي اصحاب المعارض الا
بعدين الان
الاولويه للعملاء الافراد نعم لكن لازال
في قله في عدد السيارات زي ما قال معاي
الوزير قبل شويه نعم هذه الاشكاليه كلها
اتفضل شكرا جزيلا لك اشكرك على تواجدك على
هذه الافاده من جده خبير السيارات المختصه
ايضا ماجد الشيخي
في الرابعه بعد قليل
جوله في متحف الشريف بالطائف مقتنيات
نادره تحاكي ماضي المحافظه في غرب
السعوديه
اسلحه الغرب معيار روسيا للدفاع عن حدودها
بوتين يتهمونيتو بانه شريك في جرائمك
رئيسها سقفه فيينا يزور الرياض ويؤكد صبر
والشجاعه هما طريقا الوئام بين الاديان
جدل حول مواصفات السيارات في السعوديه
المواصفات اقل والاسعار اعلى ودعوات
للرقابه على الوكلاء
وترقب لنصف نهائي ابطال
الهلال يواجه الدحيل القطري الاماله
بالوصول الى نهاء القاري
اهلا بكم من جديد يترقبه سكان العاصمه
الرياض الانتهاء من مشروع المسار الرياضي
الذي يشكل نقله نوعيه في مستقبل المدينه
وجوده الحياه فيها زميل العنود العبدلي
تعود لتوثق ما يجري في المشروع الان
بتقنيه الواقع المعزز
يمكنك ان
تتجول في المسار الرياضي احد اكبر مشاريع
التطوير الحضاري في الرياض واطول متنزه
طولي في العالم الذي يمتد على 135 كم في
العاصمه السعوديه ويمكنك ممارسه اي رياضه
تريد في هذا المسار ركوب الدراجات المشي
الجري وحتى ركوب الخيول ورياضات اخرى في
خمسين وجهه متنوعه يحتضنها هذا المسار
يمكنك ايضا التجول بحريه في انحاء هذا
المشروع الضخم الذي يربط شرق الرياض
بغربها دعونا نعود الى واقع المشروع الان
كيف تجري الاعمال والى اي مرحله وصلت لا
يزال مسار الرياضي مشاهدينا في مرحلته
الاولى التي تتضمن اعمال البنيه التحتيه
ومنها مسارات ومحطات الدراجات مسارات
الخيول اضافه الى تنفيذ المباني العامه
والتشجير وجسور المشاه وقبلها اعمال الفن
العام النطاق الجغرافي مشاهدينا لاولى
مراحل المسار الرياضي تتكون من اربع مناطق
الاولى منطقه وادي حنيفه بطول 22 كيلو متر
المنطقه الثانيه جسر الدراجات الذي يمتد
على طول 900 متر والذي سينفذ على طريق
الامير محمد بن سلمان وتم الانتهاء من 33
عمودا وتصنيع الهياكل المخصصه للجسر الذي
سيكون وجهه لمحبي الدراجات
ثالث مناطق المرحله الاولى من المشروع
يبلغ طولها
1500 متر اضافه الى المنطقه الرابعه وهي
نفق تقاطع طريق الامير تركي الاول مع طريق
الامير محمد بن سلمان طراز المباني
المجاوره للمسار الرياضي لن يكون تقليديا
حيث اطلق كود عمراني خاص بالاحياء
المحاذيه للمشروع ما يعني ان المرافق
الواقعه على طريق الامير محمد بن سلمان
ستنفذ بناء على مبادئ العماره السلمانيه
التي تستند على مركز مرتكزين رئيسيين
الاستدامه والاصاله
يستقبل متحف الشريف للتراث في مدينه
الطائف غربيه السعوديه زواره يوميا وذلك
في نافذه تاريخيه تحاكي الطرق القديمه في
المنطقه المتحف تصل مساحته الى نحو 7000
متر مربع واستغرق بناؤه واعداده نحو عشره
اعوام ليصبح من اكبر المتاحف في الطائف
ويتضمن قسما للسيارات القديمه وقسما لعرض
اسلحه معروفه منذ القدم في الطائف
بانواعها المتعدده فضلا عن قسم الحرف
اليدويه والفعاليات الاخرى
سعود الخلف ينضم الينا من احد متاحف
الطائف حياك الله سعود ناخذ معك جوله الله
الله الله الله الله الله من قدك هذه
بمناسبه يوم التاسيس ولا
شفت كيف يعني احنا قاعدين نلحق يوم
التاسيس الاحتفالات لا زالت مستمره في
كثير من مدن المملكه ومحافظاتها فقلنا يلا
خلينا نستغل هذه الفرصه ونتواجد في هذا
المتحف اللي يعتبر من اكبر المتاحف في
السعوديه ككل وكما ذكرت يعني يتجاوز
مساحته 7000 متر مربع وفي 25
قسم من الاقسام التي تعود فينا الى الزمن
الجميل في كثير من الامور خالد وخليناه في
البدايه اعطيك بس نبذه عن اللي انا لابسه
العقال المقصب ومعي المجمع ومعي البندق
المجمع والمجند المجند طبعا خاص بالرصاص
بالبنادق الناريه ولكن احنا حبينا نشكل
شوي حتى يعني نوصل الى اكبر جزء من
الجماليات في الزمن الجميل انا اقف الان
بجوار الخياط ومعي الاستاذ علي شريف صاحب
هذا المتحف اللي اخذ وقت كبير في تجهيزه
وراح المعلومات التفصيليه ابو حسن الله
يعطيك العافيه على الشغل الجميل هذا
والزمن الجميل اللي رجعتنا له احنا جنب
الخياط عطنا نبذه عن الخياط والملبوسات
اللي موجوده تبغى الخياط ولا تبغى المتحف
كله المتحف جمعه اخذ مني اكثر من ثلاثين
سنه تقريبا
تاسيس المتحف فوق 20 سنه يمر بخمسه وعشرين
قسم تقريبا احنا في السوق الشعبي هذا
السوق الشعبي هذا الخياط طبعا الخياط عندك
الثياب اللي بني سعد ميسان بالحارث ذوائح
الطائف زي الهدا الشفا بني مالك هذه
الثياب اللي هذه لقيت لها اقبال كبير في
يوم التاسيس اكيد وهذه يا ابو حسن والله
الناس اللي خيطتها تقول تسوى اكثر من عشره
الاف واكثر
احنا عشان الوقت نبغى ناخذ بشكل سريع الان
جبل مصوراتي حظنا احنا في الوقت
هذا المصوراتي
وجنبهم قبل كم سنه استخدمه 60 سبعين سنه
تقريبا الكاميرا الثابته والكاميرات
المتنقله والاستديو حق التصوير الله
وبعدها عندنا الفوال
الفوال والقهوه الان احنا في السوق الشعبي
هذا السوق الشعبي مكتمل يعني هذه الحياه
اللي كانت في
المنطقه الغربيه طبعا في 70 80 سنه السوق
الشعبي يكون زي كذا اي نعم
محمود معانا بشكل سريع على المنتجات
الدكان فيه الحبوب بانواعها في البسكوت في
الحلاوه في الدخان في الصابون فيها الزيت
في كل شيء خاص
بالبيت وزي مثلا زيت السيارات
البارد الغاز كل شيء
تاريخها ولا شغاله والبيض هذه للبيض خلي
البيض
عدم استعمالها طيب نروح لمين
للالعاب الالعاب الاطفال قديما
واغلبها ولا لا يعني لعبت فيها ولا لا
شيختك بختك انا ما لحقت عليها
لا خالد خالد خالد خالد
يقوم باكثر من دوري اللي هو الحلاق الحلاق
والحجامه والتقليع الاضراس
وعنده شنطه متنقل يروح البيوت يعني يعني
طبيب متنقل خالد جيت عند المزين
جرب انت وخلينا يعني نجرب فيك وبعدين
في مصلح البنادق النحاس مو انا اقول انت
جربت قبلي يعني بحكم السن يعني
نحاس الحداد النجار
بس عشان الوقت يعني ما يداهمنا احنا عندنا
هنا اكثر اكثر من محل السروجي القطان طبعا
الناس اللي شغاله في ذي كلهم ايدي سعوديه
يعني حرفيين وانت جايب كل الادوات اللي
كانوا يستخدمونها في ذاك الزمن في ذاك
الزمن وعندي حرفين يشتغلون في نفس الشكل
والله الحين بننتقل الى القسم قسم الترفيه
والفن والطرب والسينما ايش اللي قاعد يصير
الان تعال يا محمود هذا الفنان حجاب الله
يرحمه
[موسيقى]
مين اللي يغني
الله الله يرحمه ويغفر له
[موسيقى]
قاعد اشوف سينما روادي تلفزيونات حتى قطع
الغيار
يصلح الساعات
الساعات هذه قديمه جدا
ويصلحها الخربانه لو ابي اشتري انا منك
الساعات هذه
عرض طبعا هذا قسم التلفونات هذا السنترال
الملك سعود تمام ايوه هذا سنترال الملك
سعود طبعا اول اتصال اجري مع الملك سعود
رحمه الله عليه والملك فاروق من الحويه من
السنترال احنا بس بناخذكم على اخر قسم
اللي نقدر نصور معاكم اللي هو السيارات
والجماليات اللي موجوده فيها عندنا هنا
الدوريه وعندنا سيارات اعطينا بس كذا
ونبدا سري والله سريعه هذه جننتني سريعه
خالد بيهرب من تاريخه
[موسيقى]
هذه اقدم سياره موديل 26 هذه الدوريه زمان
لما كانوا يشغلوا الونانات هذا الونان
حقهم كان يشتغل باليد يا خالد اعتقد انت
تذكر تذكر هذا الامر يعني
[ضحك]
هذه عاد اقدم اقدم سياره موجوده عند
المتحف عمرها
1926 وهي الفورد طبعا في كثير وفي الهندل
في كثير من الاقسام احنا ما نقدر ناخذكم
في كل المتحف ولكن المتحف غني بالتراث
القديم للمنطقه الغربيه وحسب ما قال لي
الاستاذ علي بانه يعني من سنه الهجريه كم
المتحف اكثر من عشرين سنه
من الصفر
متحف ولا اجمل جدا شكرا لك على هذه الجوله
الرائعه يا سعوديه يعطيك العافيه سعود
الخلف من احد متاح في الطائف شكرا
عميد الكباتنه لقب مجاز يطلق على الشاب
السعودي جابر المطيري والذي حقق رقما
قياسيا في تطبيقات النقل حيث بلغ عدد
الرحلات التي انجزها ثلاثين الف رحله
وبقيمه ماليه وصلت لمليون ونصف المليون
تجبد جابر يرويها لنا زميل عبد المحسن
الحربي نتابع
قضى جابر اكثر من عقدين من عمره في العمل
في قطاع النقل من سيارات الاجره التقليديه
حتى انتقل للتطبيقات التوصيل انجز اكثر من
ثلاثين الف رحله ليحقق الرقم الاعلى بين
اقرانه وبلغت قيمه الرحلات الماليه مليونا
ونصف المليون ريال انا بديت من 2011 في
احدى التطبيقات كانت موجوده في وقتها وكان
تستقبل التكاسي واشتغلت يعني شغل بصراحه
اربع سنوات معاهم
بصراحه كنت
اشتغل في
اليوميه كنت يعني تخيلوا اطلع السته
الصباح ما ارجع الا عشره 11 في الليل يعني
يوميا اصبح جابر او عميد الكباتنه كما
يطلق عليه مرشدا لاكثر من خمسين الف سائق
ضمن مجموعه ارشاديه تضم كباتن اخرين هموم
يتبادلها مع نظرائه ابرزها جشع النقل
التشاركي التي اخذت اكثر من نصف المبلغ
الذي حققه وهو المليون ونصف المليون ريال
يعني النسب عاليه من التطبيقات كامله
يعني ياخذ اربعين في المئه خمسه واربعين
في المئه طيب انا
اشتغل واتعب واخر شيء يعطيني مثلا يحط
عروض على حس الكابتن يحط عروض على حسن
ياخذ عشره ريال وانا استفيد يعني يسعى
جابر الى الحصول على تمويل كافي لفكره
تطبيق خاص بالهواتف المحموله يهدف الى حل
مشكله اكتشفها اثناء عمله كسائق
وانا بديت فيه من 2019
اني اسوي تطبيق احتكاك مع الاسره المنتجه
سواق يعني اوفر والتطبيقات هذه وعلى كذا
دائما اواجههم
وكان نبغى يعني شيء يجمعنا وكذا وسويت
تطبيق اجمع الاسره المنتجه في المنصه
واحده توصيل طلباتها وعظم منتجاتهم
بدنا نجربهم يعني ان يكون الاسر منتجه
بدل ما هي محلي يكون براند عالمي يواجه
جابر صعوبات في النجاح كرائد اعمال لم
يتفرغ بعد لمشروعه فبجانب عمله صباحا لا
تزال تطبيقات النقل تاخذ من وقته في ظل
بحثه عن ممول لمشروعه
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض موسم
عقرب الدسم سينتهي بعد اسبوعين وفيه
سيتساوى طول الليل مع طول النهار تقويم مع
خالد الزعل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ابرد نجوم السماء خمسه النجم الثالث من
المربعانيه وشباط الاول وشباط ثاني
والعقرب الاوله السم والعقربه الثانيه قدم
عقربه السم ودعتنا الاسبوع المنصرم وعقرب
الدم سلمت علينا هالاسبوع وعقرب الدسم
باقي عليها اسبوعين وتواصلنا فالعقارب
ثلاث الاوله برد بالليل والنهار والثاني
برد بالليل ومعتدله بالنهار والثالثه
معتدله بالليل والنهار لسعه الاوله قاتله
لسعه الثانيه مدميه لسعه الثالثه حاره مثل
حراره الدسم لا طاح على اليد من جربوا
الكيه لا ينسى مواجعه ومن راى السم لا
يشقى كمن شرب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي نهايه موسم العقارب يتساوى فيه طول
الليل مع النهار وتشرق الشمس من المشرق
تماما وتغرب من المغرب تماما ويبدا يطول
النهار على حساب الليل لمده ثلاثه شهور
تقريبا من طول الغيبات جاب المعاذير بهزما
ما عاد فيها غنايم لا تقول هالمره ترى
غيبتي غير ما عاد تفرق لو تبي تغيب
دايم
[موسيقى]
الختام بالعناوي
رئيسها ساقفه فيينا يزور الرياض ويؤكد
الصبر والشجاعه هما طريق الوئام بين
الاديان
جدل حول مواصفات السيارات في السعوديه
المواصفات اقل والاسعار اعلى ودعوات
للرقابه على الوكاله
وترقبون النصف نهايه ابطال اسيا الهلال
يواجه الدحيل القطري امال في الوصول الى
النهائي
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]